cela nous épuise physiquement et
mentalement
[Applaudissements]
loïc et geoffroy de l'aftu les sont deux
frères explorateurs animés par une
passion commune l'eau
[Musique]
pour leur cinquième expédition ils ont
choisi de sillonner l'amérique du sud en
side-car à la rencontre des populations
locales
en cinq mois de la vie de sao paulo a
soif et à la terre de feu inhabitée ils
ont parcouru plus de 14 mille kilomètres
motivés par cette question
naître usages de l'eau témoins utiles de
notre lien la nature
[Musique]
hier niel parfois on n'a que des
éléphanteaux victimes de braconnage
particulièrement brutale car
malheureusement les bébés sont souvent
témoin non seulement du meurtre de leur
mère mais aussi la voix se faire
massacrer des coupes et une brochette a
dû je crois que les éléphants sourient
c'est ce que je vois chez des petits
leurs expressions faciales change
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt
france pour une heure et demie
d'émission émission consacré une
nouvelle fois à la crise du coronavirus
voici les titres le coronavirus et la
france qui compte ce lundi 19 1856 cas
confirmés soit à 3176 de plus qu'hier le
bilan de l'épidémie s'élève à 860 décès
très bientôt une semaine de confinement
le conseil scientifique rendra demain
ses conclusions sur l'étendue du nom des
mesures de restriction emmanuel macron
sans poserait un confinement total mais
se dire est favorable un meilleur
contrôle selon des participants à une
réunion avec les représentants des
cultes religieux la pandémie s'accélère
mais nous pouvons changer sa trajectoire
alerte l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
quinze mille morts à travers le monde et
plus de 350 milles car recensés dans 74
pays au total
le report des jeux olympiques de tokyo
je cite pourrait devenir inévitable
selon le premier ministre japonais en
chine l'espoir avec une reprise
progressive de l'activité à one bertreau
berceau du kobe 19
[Musique]
la récession mondiale pourrait être pire
que pendant la crise financière de 2008
selon le fmi qui indique une reprise de
la croissance mondiale en 2021 à
condition que les bonnes mesures soient
prises des vingt-sept de l'union
européenne valley de la suspension des
règles de discipline budgétaire
une décision inédite la fed elle annonce
ne plus fixer désormais de limites à ses
achats de bons trésor et de titres
hypothécaires
[Musique]
septième jour de confinement donc en
france les rues sont majoritairement
déserte à paris dans toutes les autres
villes françaises selon un nouveau bilan
du ministre de la santé ce soir
l'hexagone compte 186 décès en 24 heures
de plus portant le nombre total à 860
8675 patients sont actuellement
hospitalisés
le conseil scientifique doit quant à lui
rendre demain ses conclusions sur
l'étendue et la durée du confinement
emmanuel macron de son côté s'opposerait
un confinement total mais se dire est
donc favorable à un meilleur contrôle
en attendant les commerces alimentaires
restent ouverts non sans inquiétude
cynthia lauvergeon avec grégoire douce
et les magasins de proximité essentiel
continue de tourner à plein régime
après la ruée du début de confinement
les petits commerces principalement
alimentaires s'organise et reste
mobilisée matériel de protection mesures
barrières horaires réaménagés
les enseignes de centre de faire le
nécessaire pour réduire les risques de
contamination en alléguant en est les
masques on a une séparation entre nous
et les clients on a des lingettes pour
désinfecter toutes les 15 minutes les
caisses nettoyer le matériel que
j'utilise les clients donc c'est un peu
rassurant après il y aura petit ange
ayora toujours au pardon une petite
inquiétude quand on vient travailler
parce qu'on sait pas quelle personne est
porteur du virus
d'autant plus que la personne peut être
porteurs et porteuses et sans symptômes
on ferme à 19 heures donc on ceux de
l'après midi comme moi on vient plutôt à
13 heures vu qu'on ferme à 19h et même
ça des fois on a des clients des
retardataires qui viennent s'il doit la
voix de l'est s'il n'est pas temps bien
les marchands appellent leurs clients à
limiter au strict nécessaire leur venue
au supermarché une règle respectée avec
parcimonie
je sors à peu près une fois par jour
deux fois par jour bon comme je pas
accumulé trop de choses parce que je
fais les courses au jour le jour je
passais pas très longtemps dehors
certains commerçants s'agace de ce
manque de civisme
on peut pas non plus faire la police à
tous nos clients malheureusement il
faudrait les français sont des enfants
gâtés mais c'est un peu le cas c'est un
peu le cas c'est interdire d'interdire
maintenant mais malheureusement il faut
se raisonner et faut que chacun fasse un
peu la police c'est chez soi d'autres
consommateurs sont reconnaissants envers
ceux qui permettent d'assurer le
fonctionnement de la distribution
alimentaire
heureusement que les alimentations sont
ouverts parce que
moi en tant que personne seule je
travaille en télétravail en confinement
toute la semaine et ça me fait sortir
mais pas très loin autour de la maison
puisse armer un sentiment social de voir
même si on côtoie pas en reste là tu es
la distanciation
ça permet de voir des gens de voir des
humains
à l'orée du confinement le gouvernement
s'était voulu rassurant sur les risques
de pénurie et continue d'appeler les
français à être responsables dans leurs
achats et dans la cité phocéenne longues
files d'attentes malgré le confinement
devant l'hôpital de la timone
objectif rallier le pôle des maladies
infectieuses ou exerce le professeur
didier raoul ce dernier est à l'origine
de tests qu'ils jugent prometteur sur
des malades atteints du coc vide 19
son remède miracle le chloroquine
écouter certains marseillais qui veulent
se faire dépister les j'ai le nez qui
coule des mots quelques maux de tête
léger et voilà c'est sur eux surtout
pour se sécuriser pas tranquille
parce qu'on a des signes on a de la
fièvre on a les branches qui brûle on a
de la toux et des maux de tête et du cou
pour notre entourage à nous vu que mon
oncle est malade et ma mère aussi
on préfère faire les tests pour pouvoir
les protéger eux que si on a un truc
comme ça on nous donne un traitement et
et on les protège parce que ils ont plus
de risques de mourir que nous j'ai pas
vraiment de symptômes qui sont flagrants
dont j'ai une petite ou parfois je me
sens pas très bien et comme j'ai entendu
dire que il y avait beaucoup plus de cas
comme le pense et je préfère protéger ma
famille et venir faire dépister pour
savoir ce qu'est le cobra virus alors
cette question évidemment la clan qui me
pourrait-elle être nos produits miracles
un essai clinique sur quinze jours est
lancé avec l'appui du ministre de la
santé olivier verront les détails avec
lmh et medjahed
tout est parti de l'institut hospitalo
universitaires méditerranée infections
l'équipe du professeur didier raoult a
injecté à 24 patients atteints du
courant d'un virus une dose de plats
cnil
c'est le nom du médicament commercialisé
avec une molécule dérivée de la
chloroquine après six jours de
traitement le virus a disparu chez trois
quarts de ses patients selon cette étude
les effets seraient encore plus
impressionnant combiné avec deux
l'azithromycine un antibiotique utilisé
contre la pneumonie bactérienne en
comparaison 90 % des patients traités
sans chloroquine à nice et avignon
serait encore contagieux au bout de
cette même période
christian estrosi a annoncé ce dimanche
le recours aux traitements à la
chloroquine au chu de nice pour des
patients atteints du coc vide 19 testé
positif aux coronavirus le maire de nice
indiqué suivre lui-même ce protocole
j'ai obtenu satisfaction
nice et son chu validé et a provisionné
pour mettre en place le protocole du
professeur didier raoul avec
consentement des familles il serait
souhaitable que dans les mêmes
conditions
la médecine de ville soit habilité à le
prescrire l'épousé de christian estrosi
s'est également exprimée publiquement
pour dire qu'elle avait bénéficié de ce
traitement
laura temujin indiqué s'être rétabli en
48 heures un essai clinique pour évaluer
des traitements expérimentaux dont celui
à base de chloroquine a débuté ce
dimanche en france c'était c'est piloter
depuis lyon baptisée discovery
il va inclure 3200 passions parmi
lesquels 800 francs c'est positif au
coronavirus j'ai autorisé plusieurs
essais cliniques en france dont un essai
chloroquine pour plusieurs centaines de
malades hospitalisés je communiquerai
chaque résultat positif ou négatif
plusieurs essais sont également en cours
aux états unis pour mesurer les effets
secondaires éventuels de la chloroquine
dans le traitement du kobe 19
le président donald trump lui-même se
montre optimiste hydroxy chloroquine et
azithromycine prises ensemble ont une
réelle chance d'être l'un des plus
grands changeur de jeu de l'histoire de
la médecine la chloroquine peu chers et
souvent recommandé lorsque l'on prévoit
de se rendre en zone infestée par le
parasite du paludisme transmis par les
moustiques
cependant ce médicament peut avoir des
effets indésirables chez les seniors ou
associés à certaines familles
d'antibiotiques
d'ailleurs la chloroquine n'est plus
prescrite
aujourd'hui en afrique puisque le
parasite à développer les résistances
prix léon conseil pour la santé publique
s'est réuni ce soir pour discuter des
différents traitements envisageables le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand est
revenu sur leurs recommandations
concernant justement la chloroquine et
côté il incite les médecins à inclure le
plus possible de malades dans les
différents essais
thérapeutiques en cours dans notre pays
car c'est le moyen le plus sûr de
déterminer rapidement si un traitement
est efficace ou s'il ne l'est pas par
ailleurs il s'est prononcé
spécifiquement sur la question de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine le haut conseil
recommande de ne pas utiliser ce
traitement
en l'absence de recommandations à
l'exception de formes graves
hospitalière sur décision collégiale des
médecins est sous surveillance médicale
strictes enfin le haut-conseil exclut
toute prescription dans la population
générale ou pour des formes non sévère à
ce stade
en l'absence dit il de toutes données
probantes et pour parler de ce
traitement expérimental à la chloroquine
nous sommes en direct avec valérie boyer
députée les républicains des bouches du
rhône bonsoir valérie aboyer merci
d'être avec nous on le rappelle vous
avez été testée positive au coronavirus
vous suivez actuellement justement le
traitement expérimental à la chloroquine
du professeur round
première question déjà comment vous
sentez-vous et comment se passe ce
traitement qu'un traitement qui est très
simple puis donc fait trois prix de
cachets par jour un matin midi et soir
donc le fait de le matin amélie a le
soir donc la cnil et plantu voilà donc
je suis traitement depuis le 17 mars
ce matin je suis allé à l'appellation
cloud pour faire un suivi
on va en journée pma charge virale a un
qui peut durer je viens de l'apprendre
et j'ai rendez vous vendredi pour
continuer le suivi
donc à mon mieux sur l'état de santé
clairement allait mieux alors le haut
conseil de santé publique vous l'avez
entendu recommande de ne pas utiliser ce
traitement à la chloroquine sauf pour
des formes graves
quelle est votre réaction vous moi j'ai
une réaction de malades
je ne peux pas me prononcer là dessus
je l'année dernier j'avais un certain
nombre d'hommes donc me suis rendu comme
tout le monde à l'infection paul denis
peyrat août qui je le rappelle est
quelque chose d'unique en europe est
quelque chose de vraiment exceptionnel
on travaille un grand savant en
l'occurrence didier raoult était et ses
équipes
j'ai été testé positif ils m'ont appelé
dans la journée et je suis rentré à
l'hôpital vers giddins kravitz ajoute la
soir j'en suis reparti de vendredi après
l'es8 crettenand donc j'ai pas me
prononcer sur le bien-fondé du
traitement moi je suis conscient que je
fais lanta je fais confiance aux états
parce que je suis parlementaire que j'ai
un avis sur la question que je ne suis
pas médecin donc je fais confiance au
médecin qui m'a fait le test et qui m'a
prescrit ce traitement c'est un
traitement que j'ai choisi c'est pas une
carte un fromage dessert avec laquelle
il c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est passé
donc je j'ai confiance par les personnes
qui m'ont suivi comment dépister qui
m'ont prescrit ce médicament
il n'empêche valérie boyer certains
patients dirai peut-être que vous avez
de la chance de pouvoir en bénéficier
parce que la communauté scientifique
restent partagés sur ce traitement l'om
est ce qui condamne l' usage de
médicaments sans preuve de leur
efficacité
didier rahout nous explique d'ailleurs
il l'a expliqué ici même sur notre
antenne c'était le 27 février donc ça
date un peu que selon lui ce traitement
était efficace
pourquoi ça met autant de temps
seulement vous on peut tout simplement
avoir la vie d'un simple citoyen sur ce
sujet je n'en fait rien tout ce que je
sais c'est que le traitement que je qui
m'a été prescrit n'est pas d'un
traitement expérimental puisque didier
raoult et que l'a expérimenté déjà
enflammé en plaques déjà pour certaines
maladies notamment le mali qui peuvent
donc y la faune et des centaines et des
centaines de personnes avec ce
traitement
vous savez que le spécialiste des
maladies intracellulaire quelques
spécialistes mondiales et notamment de
cette maladie en ce qui concerne le
colis 19
effectivement il a jugé qu'elles aient
des similitudes qu'il pouvait être
administrés à ses patients
moi sur le traitement j'ai pas vraiment
fait je ne suis pas compétente pour ça
et d'ailleurs je pense que c'est bien de
l'écouté des personnes compétentes et je
pense que didier rahout fait partie des
personnes extrêmement compétente sur le
sujet sinon il ne ferait pas le
spécialiste mondial qu'il est reconnu en
revanche là où je peux avoir un avis de
citoyen et sur les masques dont
malheureusement qu'ils sont pas encore à
disposition tous les soignants de tous
les policiers de toutes les personnes
avec qui qui vendent des produits
alimentaires de première nécessité ça se
tiendrait sujet et le deuxième avis que
je peux avoir en tant que citoyenne et
parlementaires et d'ailleurs je vais
demander au ministre dans un courrier
que nos gouvernements part dans un
courrier que nous avons adressé avec
julien joubert et d'autres
parlementaires fait que les tests de
dépistage famille à disposition du plus
grand nombre qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce qui se passe en
allemagne et ce qu'il fait passer dans
un autre grand pays la corée du sud
donc voilà les sujets sur lesquels je
peux me prononcer parce que je pense que
pour lutter contre une épidémie il faut
être aujourd'hui vous expliquer comment
justement qu'en france on ne fasse pas
des tests systématiques qui confinent
effectivement les gens venaient me dire
ça n'a rien à voir mais si parce
qu'encore et du sud précisément il teste
abondamment mais il ne confine pas tout
le monde et ils suivent d'ailleurs les
personnes malades
les malades et qu'il n'est pas malade
puis qui peut contaminer l'autre qui ne
peut pas contaminer l'autre et c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles d'ailleurs
la maladie fait moins répandu cochet
pareil pour l'allemagne en tout cas
d'après les informations que vos
confrères au journaliste relate donc ça
m'a fait un problème d'organisation et
d'un choix d'organisation le café le
gouvernement voilà et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que le test
aujourd'hui il doit être mis à
disposition de façon plus importante
d'ailleurs je crois que ce sont des
mesures qui ont été effectif et quant au
traitement jusqu'à preuve du contraire
en tout cas d'après ce que la presse
relate c'est le seul traitement qu'on
propose aujourd'hui on
aux malades atteints du clavier 2009
traitement qui a fait ses preuves dans
d'autres d'affection donc moi je suis
une patiente jeu j'ai consulté un
médecin en l'occurrence un éminent
spécialiste qui me proposent ce
traitement j'ai confiance dans son
jugement aujourd'hui deux heures
informations notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux des assesseurs testés positifs
une semaine après le premier tour des
municipales ce qu'il fallait le
maintenir selon vous ce premier tour
écoutez c'est vraiment un sujet qui est
extrêmement difficile et c'est toujours
compliqué de donner la météo de la
veille au moment où le président de la
république a pris cette décision il
avait probablement j'ose imaginer un
certain nombre d'éléments et d'ailleurs
la décision a été prise de façon très
curieuse puisque il a dit je décide de
maintenir ce premier tour des
municipales mais j'invite les personnes
de plus de 70 ans être prudent et
ensuite en quelque sorte à pas se
déplacer et la veille le premier
ministre n'a pas arrêté le scrutin mais
il a dit aux personnes fragiles de ne
pas se rendre à sortir et il a fait
fermer les restaurants les machins et
caetera et il a dit que l'adie les
écoles seraient fermées
donc c'est vrai que c'est très compliqué
afin d'assurer un scrutin dans sept
comptes dans ces conditions nous nous
avons subi ces défis est clairement le
scrutin n'a pas été sincère puisque un
bon nombre de personnes ne sont pas
rendus aux hommes aux yeux et on a vu
une chute de la participation et quant
aux personnes qui ont tenu les bureaux
de vote
eh bien elle n'avait rien pour se
protéger ou à part du gel
hydroalcoolique et à marseille je sais
que nous avions organisé de quoi nous
laver les mains alors c'est vrai que on
peut vraiment se poser la question de la
responsabilité de ces personnes qui sont
exposées à du public sans masque sans
protection et d'ailleurs le scrutin n'a
pas pu être maintenue puisque vous savez
que deuxième tour est reportée après le
confinement donc effectivement ce une
décision qui est lourde de chance mais
qui ne nous appartient pas
nous élus a fortiori de l'opposition et
c'est quelque chose qui a été décidé par
le gouvernement dont moi donc députés en
tant que candidate sur des listes à
marseille on ne m'a pas demandé mon avis
voilà et je devais assumer
l'organisation du scrutin
merci beaucoup valérie boyer députée les
républicains des bouches du rhône on
vous laisse vous reposer bon
rétablissement vous mercier en tout cas
d'avoir été en direct
et de nouveaux décès parmi les
personnels de santé aujourd'hui deux
médecins du haut rhin et de haute savoie
sont décédées après
à midi un peu plus tôt dans la journée
deux autres médecins avaient déjà perdu
la vie des suites d'une contamination au
co vite 19 portant à cinq le nombre de
médecins mort du virus en france et puis
vint résidents d'un ehpad de cornimont
dans les vosges sont morts en lien
possible avec le virus selon l'agencé
régionale de santé du grand test de la
préfecture des vosges qui s'exprimer ce
soir et pour continuer à parler de la
situation sanitaire en france nous
sommes avec un jean bernard gervais
rédacteur en chef du magazine en ligne
what's up doc bonsoir jean bernard
gervais merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france le virus qui a donc tué
huit cent soixante personnes depuis le
début de l'épidémie 2082 patients
étaient ce soir en réanimation
quelle est votre vision sur l'évolution
de la maladie en france pour vous ça
reste encore contenu où vous vous
inquiétez qu'on ait clairement vers un
scénario encore plus à l'italienne pour
le moment ce qui sûr quand on regarde
les chiffres c'est que ça reste en effet
contenu même si en effet la situation
devient de plus en plus dramatique en
annonçant 5 décès de m ça on n'a pas
annoncé non plus en fait les lycéens
affirment ya qui seront nombreuses
malheureusement en fait on n'a pas de
chiffres exacts ils vont même pas les
remonter suffisamment pertinente mais on
annonce
selon mes sources quatre à cinq
infirmières qui seraient décédées par
toujours est il que on est quand même en
dessous de 1000 morts
puisqu'on était en fête ce matin autour
des 650 je crois aux 660 morts on
observe en fait une progression une
augmentation de la progression d'à peu
près plus 20 % avec un tassement puisque
la semaine dernière on avait une
augmentation de la de l'augmentation des
décès est à peu près 50% d'un jour à
l'autre
non mais plutôt passer à 20% pour nos
mots on peut pas dire en fait que la
grande vague qu'on nous annonce ce soit
encore là
aujourd'hui la pénurie de masques quand
on a cité les décès que vous venez de
citer qu on a cité est ce qu'on peut
parler clairement d'un scandale d'état
dans un pays comme la france aujourd'hui
manqué de masques
quelle est votre réaction alors c'est
vrai qu'en 2000 lors de la crise achats
emma lorsque madame bachelot qui était
alors ministre de la santé avait stocké
un milliard de masques ffp2 on vous
parlait déjà lorsqu'on va à l'état parce
qu'on disait mais quelle gabegie mais
comment se fait-il en fait que l'argent
de l'état soit partie en fumée et
maintenant qu'on a plus de masques on
parle de nouveau prête à un scandale
d'état il vous dit en fait que le
gouvernement tout simplement a joué de
malchance puisque si la chine qui a
égayé le principal producteur de masques
n'avait pas été douché par le corona
virus on n'en serait pas là on aurait eu
autant de masques qu'il aurait fallu
toujours est il que en effet on aurait
pu en fait s'attendre à ce que la 5ème
puissance au monde puisse avoir quelques
usines qui puisse on est un plein régime
pour pallier un manque patent de la
grande usine mondiale qu'est la chine
donc oui en effet selon la manière dont
on voit les choses on peut parler on
peut il obtient ce qu'on m'a dit ah oui
on parle de plus en plus des tests
effectivement avec peut-être un
changement de doctrine sur ce point là
aussi d'ailleurs comme le recommandait
l' oms est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
clairement aujourd'hui que la france
réagit toujours avec quelques temps de
décalage alors que finalement une telle
pandémie pouvait peut-être se prévoir on
le voit au cinéma on le voit dans les
documentaires
auquel on peut voir sur certains réseaux
ce n'était pas une telle surprise d'une
pandémie comme ça non ce n'était pas des
roses ce n'était pas une vraie surprise
en même temps ça n'était pas ce que
lorsqu'on remonte en fait les
différentes pandémie que l'on a connues
2002 2003 2006 2011 à chaque fois à
chaque fois ces endémies se sont arrêtés
aux portes de l'europe par n'a pas été
touché par là des paliers on n'a pas été
tous deux touchés par les autres
coronavirus on avait fait les stocks
il ya maintenant un peu plus il ya dix
ans de cela exactement et on n'avait pas
été douchés donc finalement ce spectre
de la pandémie qui allaient en fait
envahir l'europe
il restait comme vous l'avez dit en fait
un scénario de science fiction
on a été pris de court en effet on a été
pris de court sur les masques on a été
pris de cours de la même manière sur les
tests et maintenant la france gère la
pénurie
en attendant en effet que i les stocks
de masques et les stocks de tête
puissent être fournis par des pays dits
acp d'ailleurs en grande partie et puis
cela servira à mettre en place une
véritable politique de lutte de 40 de
guerre comme l'annoncé le pésident macro
mais de véritables guerres là pour le
moment on est vraiment dans une drôle de
guerre pour filer la métaphore avec les
vagues airs qu'on a connus au xxème
siècle à aujourd'hui justement le
confinement semble est la seule réponse
entre guillemets disponible de la part
de la france confiner les français
attendre que l'épidémie marque le pas
pour le moment oui étant donné en fait
qu'on n'a pas de protection suffisante
qu'il s'agisse de masques qu'il s'agisse
de également en fait des tests on n'a
pas non plus en fait de traitement ou
n'a pas non plus de vaccins
les traitements se font attendre ce qui
est normal ce n'est pas une critique en
soi mais des traitements auprès de
plusieurs mois avant en fait d'être
belle idée d'être distribuer le vaccin
c'est pareil on travaille sur plusieurs
en fait the beast mais pour nos bons en
effet le simple fait de confiner les
gens mais alors encore faudrait-il en
fait les confiner de manière extrêmement
strictes ce qui n'est pas le cas aussi
en france donc on hésite entre un
confinement total qui serait street et
qui permettraient réellement en fait
deux
protéger la population et des annonces à
venir de futurs tests de futurs masque
vous voyez on est il a quand même dans
un espèce de flou artistique qui devrait
à mon avis est exact éclaboussé le
gouvernement dès lors en vrai que la
crise sera passée une question rapide
aussi on en parle de plus en plus alors
que ça fait longtemps que lui en parle
le dr raul de sa chloroquine enfin de sa
chloroquine en tout cas selon lui
traitement efficace pour lutter contre
ce virus
ce soir le haut conseil de sécurité
publique recommande de ne pas l'utiliser
sauf pour des formes graves
quelle est la vision du spécialiste sur
ce point jean verdun gervais c'était à
mon sens c'était attendu une telle
intervention était attendu dans le sens
où le professeur avocats avaient
multiplié depuis en fait de trois jours
la distribution de tests ce qui n'est
pas interdit en soi mais surtout la
distribution de traitements comme vous
l'a dit valérie boyer qui a elle-même s
qualité de malades mais aussi de
parlementaires pu avoir accès à un
traitement or il se trouve en fait que
pour avoir un traitement avec un
médicament dans une indication bien
précis il faut en fait une autorisation
se rappelle une autorisation de mise sur
le marché ou alors de manière temporaire
expérimental ils entendent une
autorisation parentale temporaire
d'utilisation une à telus or le
professeur ruth n'avait ni l'un ni
l'autre il le savait et le permis
d'aider pertinemment inca jour ou
l'autre les ministères de la santé
allaient sévir c'est ce qu'a fait en
fait olivier ferrand ce soir c'était
attendu à mon avis en fait le professeur
véran le professeur à ce qu'ils aient
mois le procès d'un raout en a profité
pour accumuler des données pendant ces 2
3 jours de laps de temps pendant lequel
aucun décret aucun arrêté ne
l'interdisait en fait de faire ces
expérimentations il a accueilli des
données qui vont lui permettre de
consolider cette fois ci son étude
clinique parce qu'il faut rappeler que
la première étude clinique sur laquelle
il se basait dont il a rendu publiques
les données le 13 mars dernier nous
comporter que 24 à 24 patiente à 20,24
passion il est déjà possible en fait de
pouvoir annoncer un traitement valable
donc avec le nombre l'es1 certainement
les centaines en fait de patients qu'il
a pu traiter d'ici quelques jours on
pourrait peut-être
voir cette fois ci des résultats
scientifiques un peu plus probant de la
part en fait du redresseur out merci
jean bernard gervais merci d'avoir été
avec nous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons donc sur cette
crise du coronavirus est un autre débat
qui fait rage la désinfection alors que
de nombreux pays comme l'espagne ou la
chine ont décidé de désinfecter les rues
la france ne prévoit pas d'en faire
autant des questions persistent sur
l'efficacité de ce grand nettoyage
notamment sur sa capacité à stopper le
virus certaines villes ont néanmoins
décidé de tester des infections
notamment à suresnes où un nettoyage
hebdomadaire est effectuée idem à nice
hu à monaco et pour en parler de
l'opération des infections des rhumes
n'est justement à monaco nous sommes en
direct avec rémy réguler directeur du
service propreté environnement de la
société monégasque d'assainissement
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france l'opération a
donc débuté ce matin comment ça se passe
bonsoir
effectivement on a démarré ce matin
l'opération de désaffection donc à
rappeler que nous avons la mission de
propreté de voirie et de salubrité donc
c'était tout naturellement qu'il fallait
faire une extension de cette mission de
salubrité pour proposer un nouveau
service à nos usagers
donc on a mis en place deux systèmes
vous voyez les images donc à la lance
donc on a quatre véhicules motorisés
avec des lanciers qui arrosent les
trottoirs avec deux loups qui contient
une solution bactéricide dont qui ont
les mêmes problèmes vertus que les gels
hydroalcooliques et puis on a un
deuxième service de
de nettoyage avec du cif et un chiffon
et les produits identiques qui
permettent de nettoyer les mains
courantes et les rambardes ainsi que les
boutons d'ascenseurs ou les usagers sur
respectives de poser les mains
évidemment la question qu'on peut tous
se poser quand on voit ces jeunes cg de
ce produit ce qu'il représente une
quelconque nocivité pour les français
qui pourraient se promener dans les rues
quelques minutes après alors pour le
coup sont pas des français
ce sont des monégasques puisque c'est la
principauté de monaco mais non il n'y a
pas de nocivité puisque c'est le même
produit que nous utilisons tout au long
de l'année pour désinfecter les suit
essentiellement les laitages lettrage
d'urines où les déchets canins
donc c'est juste qu'on le fait de façon
beaucoup plus systématique et en
quantité beaucoup plus importante mais
c'est exactement le même produit avec
lequel nos salariés ont l'habitude de
travailler et y la désaffection des
ascenseurs nous avons renforcé en vérité
quelque chose qui se pratiquait déjà
tourner l'année pour combien de temps ça
va encore durer
c'est la même question vous serez
susceptible de poser aux médecins pour
savoir comme étant ça va encore durer
dans nous suivrons l'actualité nous ont
mis ce service en place sept jours sur
sept et nous assurerons tout le temps
nécessaire que la situation le
nécessitera merci beaucoup auraient mis
réguler directeur du service propreté
environnement de la société monégasque
d'assainissement
merci à vous et on reviendra dans
quelques instants sur la crise du
coronavirus en france et dans le monde
avec cette pandémie qui fait rage dans
74 pays on dénombre plus de quinze mille
décès
rester avec mon sur rt france
[Musique]
ils sont élevés dans un seul but
ils ont un super pouvoir
il commence à s'entraîner dès le plus
jeune âge
huit mois de formation intense
ce sont des rats est il sauvé des vies
humaines
pourquoi vraiment nollywood est née au
nigeria et pas par exemple au sénégal au
mali moderne hommes d'affaires ont déjà
conduit un homme comme femme et tout le
monde et businessman etc c'est assez
impressionnant donc nollywood est
clairement le vent en poupe et les
budgets ce qui est gros budgets des
films à gros budget comme aux états unis
ou même en france d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le record de budget au
nigeria ces neuf millions de dollars et
une montée en gamme
d'un point de vue technique au niveau
des histoires racontées etc et du coup
ça implique effectivement des budgets
beaucoup plus important donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se passent et
beaucoup de pays en afrique francophone
notamment qui regarde ce qu'est ce qu'on
n'est jamais acquis et apprennent et qui
essayent de
de faire parler
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre direct 8 et france
bienvenue à tous et la pandémie due
nouveau coronavirus qui a tué plus de
dix mille personnes en europe selon le
dernier bilan
dans l'aude on dénombre plus de 350
mille cas de pandémie s'accélère selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
l'om s il est primordial d'attaquer le
virus de manière ciblée écouter demander
aux gens de rester chez eux et établir
d'autres mesures de distanciation
physiques sont un moyen important de
ralentir la progression du virus et de
gagner du temps bah tu verras défense et
ce sont des mesures de défense qui ne
nous aiderons pas à gagner pour gagner
nous devons attaquer le virus avec des
tactiques agressives et ciblé et agressé
est un abri ça il faut tester chaque cas
suspect isolées et soignées chaque cas
confirmés et suivre et mettre en
quarantaine
chaque contact étroit clause contact et
en italie plus de 600 de plus que six en
demeure par dont 24 heures soit 6000 78
décès au total une hausse journalière de
11% la plus faible en valeur absolue
depuis le début de l'épidémie
peut-être donc un fléchissement lacour
bah qui donne de l'espoir à la péninsule
clémence pital l'italie pays le plus
touché d'europe avec un scénario que
redoutent toutes les autres régions du
monde
dans certains territoires italien la
situation paraît hors de contrôle
ce week-end la pandémie a fait près de
1400 morts en moins d'un mois
plus de 5500 décès ont été enregistrés
ce crématorium situé dans le nord de
l'italie est surchargé
270 incinération une semaine pour nous
il a toujours était impératif de traiter
le défunt avec le plus grand respect
cependant à cause du manque d espace
nous avons été obligés de laisser des
cercles sur le sol de la terrasse pour
faire de la place pour les palettes
évidemment ils sont les premiers à
partir mais en attendant ils doivent
passer une journée entière dans cet état
et ça me fait mal au coeur mais nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix l'angoissent
gagne le pays et la réalité dépasse
parfois la fiction
à l'image de cette histoire à peine
croyable où près de 650 mille masques
envoyé par la chine ne sont jamais
arrivés en italie
les autorités tchèques ont réquisitionné
la marchandise lors d'une escale à
prague pour les distribuer aux hôpitaux
locaux
une erreur selon la république tchèque
qui a présenté ses excuses à ses
homologues italiens la chine a aussitôt
renvoyé un million de masques à l'italie
sans escale cette fois ci elle a réussi
qui apporte son aide à l'italie une
centaine de virologues militaires
doivent arriver dans les prochaines
heures sur la péninsule italienne des
personnes expérimentées dans la lutte
contre la propagation d'une épidémie
la correspondante à moscou le
correspondant à moscou
antoine claireaux pour les précisions
c'est depuis une base militaire située
en banlieue de moscou que décollent les
avions à destination de la péninsule
italienne des appareils militaires à
bord desquels se trouvent des unités
mobiles de désinfection du matériel
médical mais aussi du personnel soignant
et des médecins spécialistes neuf avions
iliouchine 76 de transport militaire des
forces aérospatiale russe ont transporté
près de 100 spécialistes militaires
russes du matériel et de l'équipement
depuis l'aérodrome militaire de
tchkalovski vers l'italie pour prêter
assistance dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le coronavirus et se sont même 10
avions qui sont partis depuis la journée
du dimanche le dixième ayant décollé
dans l'après midi
pour l'italie c'est une aide qui est
plus que bienvenu je tiens à exprimer la
grande satisfaction et la gratitude de
tous les italiens pour l'aide russe dans
un moment aussi difficile pour la
république italienne
je tiens à vous remercier pour le
matériel et les spécialistes venus de
russie pour aider l'italie
sinon en russie le nombre de cas
confirmés
passé ces dernières 24 heures de 367 à
438 et à moscou on recense la majorité
de ces nouveaux cas le maire de la ville
s'est adressé à ses administrés pour
leur soumettre un nouveau train de
mesures les personnes âgées en
particulier sont désormais invités à
rester confinées chez elles mais pour le
reste de la population
il ne s'agit que de recommandations est
encore loin d'un confinement total est
stricte tel qu'on le connaît en france
et la russie accusé de vouloir semer la
panique sur le coronavirus les états
unis et l'union européenne disent
émettre des doutes sur les intentions de
moscou washington et bruxelles dénonce
une campagne je cite de désinformation
orchestrée par les médias russes et les
médias pro kremlin propos du coc vite 19
karine abéché golovkov professeur invité
à l'université d'état de moscou dénonce
ces accusations dans un article sur
réseau international.net et pour cet
universitaire la prise en charge de la
crise du corps d'un virus est totalement
différente en russie l'ampleur que prend
cette crise du chrono virus dans les
pays occidentaux est absolument
inacceptable lorsque l'on compare avec
la façon de traiter et gérer en russie
on a l'impression que nous sommes dans
deux mondes totalement différents
d'un côté vous avez en russie un
gouvernement et un état qui fonctionne
et qui a dès le départ pris des mesures
systématiques de contrôle aux frontières
de suivi des personnes à risque de
confinement des personnes positives
c'est pas un régime comme on le voit en
france notamment qui met sa population
enfermée à domicile à ce qui est
incapable d'avoir des hôpitaux qui
fonctionnent ce n'est quand même pas la
russie qui a obligé macro par exemple à
ne faire aucun contrôle dans les
aéroports à l'arrivée ce n'est pas la
russie qui a obligé macro à liquider les
stocks de masques
ce n'est pas la russie qui a obligé
macro non plus à ne pas gérer la
question de la souveraineté médical de
la france et les mesures contre la paix
de portneuf
ducobu 19 s'intensifie également en
afrique le sénégal l'un des plus touchés
à l'ouest du continent a mis en place
une campagne de désinfection sur son
plus grand marché à dakar les précisions
de mehdi et ski fis avec les images de
louis d'inga une population sénégalaise
de plus en plus exposés à la montée du
coronavirus face à cette situation le
gouvernement a décidé de mettre en place
de nouvelles mesures parmi elles la
désinfection de l'un des plus grands
marchés de dakar situé au coeur du
quartier de la médina
celui ci a été démantelée pour un
nettoyage en urgence cette opération est
de grande envergure et a été initiée par
le maire de dakar pour assainir le
marché en accord avec les solutions de
l'état nous sommes en période de
pandémie avec koné virus qui fait le
tour du globe
et c'est dans ce cadre là que nous avons
lancé cette opération de grande
envergure dans tous les marchés de dakar
aujourd'hui c'est la médina mais les
autres marchés vont suivre le produit
désinfectant est là pour anéantir le
virus et l'ensemble des virus qui sont
dans le marché nous allons attaquer les
marchés les gares et les domiciles des
cas confirmés et suspects autorités
riverains tous veulent s'assurer de bien
lutté contre le coronavirus à l'image de
l' opération de désinfection du marché
ne veulent prendre aucun risque
ce qui nous intéresse c'est seulement le
bien-être des populations
les commerçants viennent prennent leur
argent et s'en vont et laisse les
populations nous on se préoccupe du
bien-être avec plusieurs dizaines de cas
confirmés le sénégal est le pays
d'afrique de l'ouest le plus touché
derrière le burkina faso dès ce vendredi
dakar avait annoncé une fermeture de ses
frontières terrestres et aériennes et
les etats unis doivent également faire
face à l'émergence exponentielle du
nombre de cas de corps d'un virus sur
son territoire alors même que le sénat
vient de refuser un plan de relance de
l'économie
point sur la situation avec quentin
l'eau claire les etats unis sont le
troisième pays le plus touché par la
pandémie du coronavirus en nombre de cas
avec plus de 35000 personnes infectées
et 471 mans
selon le dernier bilan de l'université
d'hopkins après avoir annoncé le test de
chloroquine pour enrayer l'épidémie
donald trump a dévoilé que la garde
nationale allait être déployé dans les
états de new york washington et la
californie l'effroi plus touchée du pays
[Musique]
nous voulons gagner la guerre aussi vite
que possible et avec le moins de morts
possibles nous voulons avoir le moins de
décès possibles aujourd'hui j'annonce
des mesures pour aider new york la
californie washington à faire en sorte
que la garde nationale puisse répondre
efficacement à cette crise en plus du
déploiement de la garde nationale
le président américain a annoncé la
construction au plusieurs hôpitaux de
campagne
en plus de grandes quantités de matériel
j'ai également demandé à l'agencé
fédérale des situations d'urgence de
fournir ce qui suit quatre grands
hôpitaux fédéraux de campagne d'une
capacité de 1000 lits pour l'état de new
york
huit grands hôpitaux fédéraux de
campagne d'une capacité de 2000 lits
pour la californie et trois grands
hôpitaux fédéraux de campagne ainsi que
quatre petits centres médicaux fédéraux
d'une capacité de 1000 lits pour l'état
de washington
côté économie un plan de relance pour
portant l'injection de 2000 milliards de
dollars dans l'économie américaine a été
présenté au sénat plan qui n'a pas
obtenu d'accord malgré plusieurs jours
de négociations les démocrates estiment
que le projet de loi avait trop de
problèmes la législation de nombreux
problèmes en tête de liste elle comprend
un important plan de sauvetage des
entreprises sans aucune protection pour
les travailleurs et pratiquement aucune
surveillance
le projet de loi était également très
troublant car les hôpitaux les états à
l'évident les travailleurs médicaux
avaient désespérément besoin d'argent
il s'agit d'une crise de santé publique
il est inexplicable de lésiner sur le
financement pour lutter contre la
pandémie à l'international les etats
unis ont proposé une aide humanitaire à
l'iran offrant fusée par le guide
suprême ali khamenei enfin les tensions
se poursuivent avec la chine
donald trump accuse toujours pékin de ne
pas avoir partagé des informations
cruciales sur la pandémie
et pendant cette pandémie coronavirus la
planète se porterait elle mieux niveau
écologie pollutions marines
atmosphérique et terrestres ont diminué
depuis que plusieurs dizaines de pays
ont imposé des règles de confinement
illustration en images
[Musique]
[Rires]
la pandémie s'accélère mais je suis nous
pouvons changer sa trajectoire selon la
sémantique de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
quinze mille morts sur l'ensemble du
globe mais bonne nouvelle l'activité
reprend progressivement en chine à wuhan
plus précisément le berceau de
l'épidémie où des habitants sont
autorisés à sortir de chez eux pour la
première fois depuis deux mois
mais le japon de son côté craint pour
ses jeux olympiques
un report semble de plus en plus
probable quentin mauclair prévue du 24
juillet au 9 août prochain les jeux
olympiques de tokyo se dirige doucement
vers un possible report en raison de la
pandémie due coronavirus prônant la
patience lors des dernières semaines
tokyo évoquent l'hypothèse pour la
première fois ses décisions du cio vont
dans le sens de la politique que j'ai
mentionnés à savoir l'organisation des
jeux olympiques dans leur intégralité
si cela devenait difficile en tenant
compte en priorité des athlètes
il pourrait devenir inévitable que nous
décidions de reporter les jo
la gouverneur de la capitale japonaise a
quant elle rappelé que la priorité
serait mis sur la santé
christophe chez nokia ce match n'est pas
au dessus en tant que représentante de
la ville organisatrice j'ai toujours
expliqué qu'une annulation des jeux
était impensable mais aussi que la
priorité était des mesures contre le
coronavirus afin de protéger la santé et
la sécurité des citoyens de tokyo depuis
quelques jours les fédérations multiplie
les déclarations allant vers un report
de l'événement dans une lettre dévoilée
ce lundi c'est la fédération
internationale d'athlétisme qui a
demandé à ce que les géo et lieu
ultérieurement
après la déclaration de shinzo abe le
comité olympique australien a déclaré
que ces athlètes devraient privilégier
leur santé et se préparer pour 2021
même son de cloche pour le canada qui
n'enverra aucun la tête à tokyo cet été
le comité olympique canadien et le
comité paralympique
canadien appuyés par leur commission des
athlètes leurs organismes nationaux de
sport et par le gouvernement du canada
ont pris la décision difficile de ne pas
envoyer des équipes canadiennes aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques au cours de
l'été 2020 leur portée géographique est
également demandée par les fédération
française de natation et de judo de son
côté le président du comité national
olympique et sportif français denis
masseglia estime que le report des jo
est inévitable à partir du moment où le
cio indique qu'il réfléchit à d'autres
solutions c'est qu'il a déjà pris
l'option de les reporter le cio a été
pas mal critiquée alors qu'il n'a jamais
dit qu'il voulait maintenir les jeux
coûte que coûte
il a simplement dit qu'il était trop tôt
pour prendre une décision
je pense que le report est inévitable
2020-2021 ou 2022 le comité
international olympique se donne
désormais quatre semaines pour prendre
une décision à propos du sort des jeux
olympiques de tokyo
mais l'espagne dépasse de son côté la
barre des 2000 morts pour plus de 28000
sens qu'à madrid qui souhaite prolonger
le confinement jusqu'au 11 avril seuls
sont autorisés les déplacements pour
faire ses courses aller au travail ou se
faire soigner robin pu elle l'espagne
frappée de plein fouet par le cos vie 19
le pays est le deuxième foyer de
l'épidémie en europe derrière l'italie
le 14 mars dernier pour faire face à
cette crise le premier ministre pedro
sanchez a décrété l'état d'alerté le
confinement de la population pour une
durée minimale de deux semaines une
situation à laquelle tentent de
s'adapter les espagnols cela nous
affecte beaucoup et encore plus ici avec
le style de vie que l'on a en espagne tu
as l'habitude de sortir beaucoup
d'échangés avec les gens etc et
maintenant il faut rester tout le temps
la maison plus les changements au
travail tu dois travailler de la maison
changer ton style de vie et ça nous
affecte beaucoup c'est une situation de
crise et nous devons tous être
responsable à d'autres échelles agir
avec responsabilité
moi je suis enfermé à la maison depuis
une semaine je sors juste pour aller
faire les courses
j'ai lu supermarché à côté c'est une
situation inquiétante pas pour la
fatalité du virus ni pour moi en tant
que jeune mais pour la population plus
âgée ou avec des problèmes qui peuvent
saturer l'hôpital et tout le système
sanitaire comme actuellement pedro
sanchez souhaite prolonger de 15 jours
l'état d' alerte
une demande qui sera examinée mercredi
par le parlement espagnol
ce samedi le chef du gouvernement a
annoncé l'achat de nouveaux tests et de
masques de protection pour faire face à
la pandémie
nous avons acheté 6 149 mille nouveaux
tests nous allons avoir un million dans
un futur proche nous avons conclu un
accord où nous sommes en train de
conclure cet accord pour importer 6
millions de nouveaux tests et dans les
prochaines heures
nous allons commencer à distribuer la
livraison de cinq cent mille masques
chirurgicaux pour les professionnels et
800000 pour les patients dans toutes les
communautés autonomes
au total 1 million 300 mille masques
les dépistages s'intensifient à travers
le pays dans le sud de l'espagne les
premiers tests en mode drive in sont
expérimentés le gouvernement a également
mobilisé les étudiants en dernière année
de médecine et en soins infirmiers ainsi
que certains retraités du domaine
médical pour faire face à l'afflux de
malades
le centre des expositions de madrid a
été transformée par l'armée en hôpital
de campagne où devraient être installés
à terme cinq mille cinq cents lits et
l'allemagne de son côté adopté un plan
de sauvetage économique de plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros inédit
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
berlin s'attend à une récession de -5 %
en 2020 les mesures de confinement qui
se durcissent outre rhin pour au moins
deux semaines un gain américaine annonce
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de deux personnes
la chancelière allemande négative selon
un premier test le gouvernent
mon instaure des amendes pouvant aller
jusqu'à vingt cinq mille euros
le gouvernement a également adopté un
plan de sauvetage de plusieurs centaines
de milliards pour protéger son économie
l'allemagne à prendre plus de 24000 qu'a
confirmé une centaine de morts nous
voulons nous assurer que la perte de
revenus de nos citoyens et compenser ou
aussi faible que possible
c'est ce qui se passe avec notre système
de sécurité sociale très classique de
sorte que quiconque perd son emploi
maintenant ce qui arrive à l'un ou à
l'autre par exemple parce que son
contrat n'était pas encore définitif
c'est qu'il est soutenu par notre
système de sécurité sociale
mais dans quelques instants rester avec
nous nous reviendrons évidemment sur
cette crise du coronavirus et ses
conséquences économiques notamment la
récession mondiale pourrait être pire
que pendant la crise financière de 2008
c'est ce qu'indique aujourd'hui le fmi
mais aussi sur les dernières annonces du
premier ministre avec notamment la
fermeture des marchés ouverts
mais avec des dérogations possibles
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les coups sont permis la stratégie
de conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillage de fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
un seul ce type de pratique une existe
sur la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez qui est sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les moyens
[Musique]
l'amérique n'a jamais connu la grandeur
elle a été fondée sur un viol et un
meurtre n'a rien n'a changé nous
préparons donc nous mêmes la réponse aux
situations auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés
[Musique]
j'ai pas confiance en ce gouvernement
j'ai pas confiance en mon président j'ai
pas confiance dans ce système
vous avez une pièce bonne soirée les
gens ici sont différents ils sont là
pour différentes raisons
certains ont perdu leur boulot d'autres
leur logement nous sommes déjà la
capitale américaine pour le nombre de
meurtres aux states mais nous sommes
aussi les premiers pour la dépendance à
l'héroïne d'action et ça peut rien y
faire à part survivre regarde regarde
c'est la jungle
tourné dans une jungle nous avons été
amenés ici très bien vous ne pouvez pas
vous débarrassez nous nous ne partirons
pas nous n'allons pas mourir sans rien
dire
[Musique]
laissez moi vivre geoffroy et loïc deux
frères aventuriers ont décidé de suivre
le cours du troisième plus grand club du
monde
les y incite notre objectif est simple
aller à la rencontre d'un fleuve
mythique qui telle une artère irrigue le
pays le plus peuplé au monde
[Musique]
en cinq mois de sa source sur les hauts
plateaux tibétains à son embouchure à
shanghai ils ont parcouru plus de 7000
km à moto est entré cycle à la
découverte du lien qui unit l'homme à
l'eau
[Musique]
nous filons à toute allure vers de
nouvelles rencontres et des paysages qui
sans aucun doute vont encore beaucoup
nous surprendre
[Musique]
arrêterait ce qu'on a fini maman on a
fini maman non je suis sûr qu'on doit
mettre un terme à cette croissance
et je n'ai jamais vraiment été séduit
par l'idée de mettre des enfants au
monde parce que je sentais que le monde
n'avait pas bien et que la vie serait
synonyme pour eux de souffrance cela
nous ramène à cette idée qu'il n'y a
aucune raison de mettre plus d'enfants
au monde
vous prenez des êtres qui ont besoin
d'amour et voulait leur donner cet amour
personne ne veut en parler car tout le
monde a peur mais la survie de notre
espèce dépend vraiment de notre capacité
à résoudre ce problème s'il ne pouvons
même pas en parler on va avoir de gros
problèmes
le zéro derma pigmentosum c'est une
hypersensibilité aux rayons ultraviolets
en fait c'est une maladie génétique qui
est transmise par les deux parents dont
les deux parents sont porteurs sains de
la maladie ce qui transmettent qui se
transmettent en fait alors à leurs
enfants des enfants ne peuvent pas
s'exposer au soleil
acial comment on pourrait résumer une
journée type de votre fils qu'il faut
savoir c'est que il faut pas qu'ils
aient un millimètre de pau qui soient
exposés à la porte ces gants ses
vêtements on leur met leur masque avec
la visière qui leur permet de
de regarder à l'extérieur une fois
qu'ils y sont ma fille je veux pas
qu'elle ait une vie où il reste tout le
temps à la maison c'est pas une vie tu
auras la vie comme tout le monde et ça
je ferai tout pour que ça soit le cas
en effet l'afghanistan n'est pas un lieu
tranquille ce n'est pas un bon pays
l'afghanistan est un endroit très
dangereux pour quelqu'un de célèbre
[Musique]
abbas est devenu célèbre
avant même de réussir ses amis sur
facebook
ses camarades de classe même des gens
dans la rue et des parents disaient
qu'il ressemblait à bruce lee
chaque fois que quelqu'un m'appelle
bruce si je suis aux anges abbas ali se
présente comme bruce lee il imite les
actes des infidèles l'islam dénonce des
actes contre la religion commis par les
musulmans marc machin
il doit simplement continuer à
s'entraîner normalement vous ça peu
importe sa religion qu'ils soient
musulmans ou non
voilà quelqu'un qui ressemble à bruce
lee qui peut réussir à garder sa mémoire
vivante
cela fera revenir la figure de bruce lee
dans le cinéma et le sport c'est génial
pour la promotion du sport c'est chacun
pour soi dieu pour tous petit coup
politique n'a jamais été obligé de dire
la vie des idées courageuse des mots qui
comptent en soi vient de l'union
aujourd'hui la gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
les tueurs professionnels utilisent des
révolvers il tire deux fois par ici et
par là je m'appelle casquettes baskets
alias pop et j'étais le tueur de
confiance du peuple au sabbat j'ai tué
plus de 250 personnes de mes propres
mains
je suis tueur professionnel je tuais
pour de l'argent j'ai tué aussi par
amour et respect pour la blu escobar
avec j'aime la douleur j'ai un seuil de
douleur élevé alors je suis un homme
très religieux je suis un guerrier
j'adore le seigneur le saint-esprit ne
pouvions donc pas les humilier par
respect nous leur avons tiré deux balles
dans la tête
ensuite nous les avons des membres et
est brûlé ma part mon phrasé tués et
poser des bombes et facile pour moi je
suis un expert en terrorisme
inna ping et crimes de toutes sortes je
voulais simplement tuer pour le compte
de pablo escobar
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce lundi
toujours consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus et cette récession mondiale
qui pourrait être pire que pendant la
crise financière de 2008 selon le fmi
qui indique une reprise de la croissance
mondiale en 2021 à condition que les une
bonne mesure soit prise les 27 de
l'union va dit de la suspension des
règles de discipline budgétaire une
décision inédite la fed américaine
annonce ne plus fixer désormais de
limites à ces achats du bon trésor et de
titres hypothécaires le corona virus en
france qui compte ce lundi 19 milles 855
cas confirmés soit 3176 de plus qu'hier
le bilan l'épidémie s'élève à 860 décès
le premier ministre edouard philippe
vient de préciser que le temps du
confinement
elle pouvait durer encore quelques
semaines et annonce de nouvelles
restrictions la fermeture des marchés
ouverts avec des dérogations possibles
et les sorties sportives toujours
limitée à un rayon d'un kilomètre autour
de son habitation et une heure maximum
[Musique]
nouvelle dégringolade des marchés
financiers aujourd'hui la bourse de
paris clôture sur une chute de 3,30 2%
ce soir le cac40 qui dévisse de plus de
134 points tf1 vinci airbus saint gobain
kering totale en matière de valeur les
avertissements sur résultats
d'entreprises françaises se multiplient
selon le fonds monétaire international
le reprise de la croissance interviendra
en 2021 conditions je cible de prendre
les bonnes mesures
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec olivier delamarche économise
bonsoir olivier delamarche merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
tout d'abord sur cette analyse sur
l'occasion déjà de vous interviewez la
semaine dernière vous n'étiez pas
vraiment optimiste vous devriez dont 4
d'accord avec le fmi la récession
mondiale pour être bien pire que la
crise financière de 2008
c'est une évidence qui est triste c'est
que le fmi nous nous sortent ça
maintenant comme s'il avait découvert le
fil à couper le beurre
franchement on sait tous que ça sera
plus fort que 2008 2008 c'était c'était
quelque chose qui est arrivé pas du tout
dans les mêmes dans les mêmes conditions
que qu'aujourd'hui est donc évidemment
ça va être beaucoup plus fort en 2008
vous n'aviez pas des pays totalement
arrêtée comme aujourd'hui comme l'italie
peut l'être comme la france qui
fonctionne peut-être à 10% de ce qu'elle
de ce qu'elle devrait et que bientôt les
états unis ça sera pareil
donc on peut pas imaginer que ça soit la
même crise qu'en 2008 c'est une simple
il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir des analyses
pour ça alors quelles pourraient être
les conséquences selon vous
alors c'est vrai qu'on entend souvent
c'est peut-être dévoile à des discours
de la rue mais quand même certains
crient à la faillite des banques vous
vous iriez carrément jusqu'à ce genre de
diagnostic de prévenir toute façon les
banques elles sont elles sont en
faillite depuis
depuis un bon moment où je vous rappelle
que deutsche bank n'a pas attendu le
coronavirus pour être en faillite alors
c'était quand même une des plus belles
banques européennes donc maintenant se
poser la question à savoir s'il va y en
avoir d'autres
oui je vous l'annonçais y en avoir
d'autres donc 1 maintenant qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir justement la réaction des
marchés par rapport à quelque chose qui
était attendu aussi qui est une sorte de
japonisation de toutes les banques
centrales
vous avez la banque centrale américaine
qui a annoncé aujourd'hui que elle
faisait tapis comme poker c'est à dire
c'était open bar pour tout le monde et
donc j'achète tout n'importe quoi dans
des proportions qui sont délirantes et
donc on voit que ils ont toujours le
même réflexe 1 donc on essaie de régler
un problème en rajoutant de la dette
en imprimant massivement massivement on
sait que ça ne fera rien sur l'économie
réelle mais il ça aujourd'hui
la preuve en est voilà la réaction de
wall street on est presque à 5% de
baisse là on voit que ça n'a pas plus
d'effets maintenant sur le les marchés
financiers pourquoi mais tout simplement
parce qu'aujourd'hui le marché il est
persuadé d'une chose c'est qu'on ne peut
pas sortir de ce 2 7 de cette situation
c'est à dire que vous allez avoir petit
à petit comme la banque du japon
la fête qui va tout acheter qui achètera
aussi des actions qui achètera des
hôtels
et qui remettra sans arrêt un petit peu
plus d'argent parce que sinon s'ils ne
sont pas là et bien les marchés
s'écroule et donc mais olivier marcatel
comme votre choix la fed
enfin les banques centrales comptait
comme autre choix que de faire ça mais
c'est pas aux banques centrales
quand tu veux on pouvait se poser la
question en 2008 en 2008
ce qu'ils ont mis en place c était
nouveau ils ont fait un quantitative
easing en disant il ya un problème de
liquidités on nageait de la liquidité
mais rassurez vous après ça sera terminé
bon on a bien vu que ce n'était pas
terminé et que ça continue même encore
douze ans plus tard et ont su on s'y
remet on a interrompu pendant quelques
temps à peine et puis on s'y remet
pourquoi parce que justement c'est
quelque chose dont on ne peut pas sortir
donc ça n'est pas la solution on sait
que ça n'est pas la solution
alors c'est quoi c'est deux minutes de
plus monsieur le bourreau c'est ridicule
on va s'endetter pour des générations va
on va détruire la monnaie tout ça pour
quoi
tout ça pour tenir quelques quelques
semaines de plus
mais c'est grotesque alors qu al saleh
fillon ces ions d'avoir enfin essayons
de réfléchir autrement je veux dire on a
vu que ça ne marchait pas maintenant si
c'est pas quelque chose c'est pas comme
si c'était expérimental et que on
pouvait se dire bah peut-être que ça va
marcher ça on pouvait peut-être se le
dire en 2008 bien que beaucoup de voix à
ce moment là disaient que ça ne
marcherait pas et avec raison
et là aujourd'hui on recommence la même
chose en se disant peut-être que cette
fois ci ça a marché banon pas plus que
la première fois
alors quelles seraient les solutions
remettre tout le système à plat une
bonne foi porto tu as mais je pense
qu'il faut remettre tout le système à
plat une bonne fois pour toutes oui
parce que je pense qu'il va il va être
temps 1 de changer les équipes parce que
excusez moi pour l'instant
aucun a prouvé son efficacité donc et ça
dans tous les pays
donc changer les équipes et réfléchir
autrement là aujourd'hui je pense que ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a quand même pu voir à
l'occasion de cette crise c'est qu'il y
avait pas d'europe
l'union européenne c'est un truc qui
n'existe pas chacun tire dans son coin
chacun ferme ses frontières pendant ce
temps là il y en a un qui dit qu'il faut
pas les fermer
il ya un un stock de masques qui arrive
à prague il le confie ce que c'était
direction italie je veux dire elle est
où l'europe elle n'existe pas donc
qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui vient aider
les italiens c'est les chinois he sees
les russes et c'est même une équipe
d'infirmiers cubain c'est pas des
européens donc ça n'existe pas donc je
pense qu'à la fin de cette crise et
heureusement je pense que ça va ça va
éveiller tout le monde et notamment les
italiens je pense que ils demanderont
leur sortie de l'union européenne et
tant mieux
je veux dire on voit que c'est quelque
chose qui ne marche pas ça nous coûte
une fortune
mais ça ne marche pas c'est c'est
vraiment ces organismes européens
c'est ça me fait penser ccva ce que je
vais dire mais ça me fait penser à la
poubelle jaune de recyclage si les
recyclages des politiques qui ont échoué
dans les différentes dans les différents
pays et qu on recase en europe pour
qu'ils trouvent un boulot mais que tu
désolé mais malheureusement c'est pas la
solution
merci beaucoup olivier delamarche
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france
et pendant ce temps septième jour de
confinement en france ça pourrait durer
nous dit edouard philippe ce soir les
rues sont majoritairement déserte à
paris et dans les autres villes du pays
d'après un nouveau bilan du ministre de
la santé ce soir l'hexagone compte 186
décès en 24 heures portant le nombre
total la suite 160 morts 8675 patients
sont actuellement hospitalisés le
conseil scientifique doit quant à lui
rendre demain ses conclusions sur
l'étendue et la durée du confinement ce
soit vous le disais le premier ministre
a lancé
chez nos confrères de tf1 durcissement
des mesures de confinement à travers un
décret qu'il signera dans les prochaines
heures il a notamment précisé que pour
sortir une activité sportive ne sera
autorisée que dans un rayon d'un
kilomètre de son habitation également en
question depuis plusieurs jours il a
officialisé la fermeture des marchés
ouverts avec toutefois une possibilité
de dérogation décidée par les maires et
les préfets
enfin edouard philippe a confirmé que le
confinement devrait durer encore
plusieurs semaines sans donner plus de
précisions et pour parler de cette
pandémie nous sommes en direct avec
michel onfray philosophe
bonsoir michel onfray merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france encore
peut-être plusieurs semaines de
confirmant de confinement s'est pas
vraiment une surprise qu'elle et vous
votre réaction
oui bon c'est pas une surprise on voit
bien que le président de république
navigue à vue qu'il cody hay et qu'il va
et vient séduit en même temps c'est en
même temps à droite à gauche on va à
droite on va à gauche on ne sait pas
trop ce qu'on fait il y avait une
politique possible une autre politique
possible qui n'était pas celle qu'il a
choisie celle du caennais sont
plurielles qui aurait été effectivement
de confiner très vite et très tôt en
faisant de manière individuelle et
personnelle en prison telle sorte que
des tests soient effectués sur les gens
individuellement personnellement
massivement pour faire de telle sorte
que effectivement on confine mais pâle
la pop à lui la population entier la
totalité de la france
regardez commencé à fonctionner à taïwan
regarder comment ça fonctionne et en
allemagne et les allemands sont à moins
de 100 morts ces jeunes ont beaucoup
trop mais c'est quand même tout à fait
autre chose que ce qui nous arrive à
nous donc effectivement il y avait une
autre politique possible mais on ne
sache pas que mba qu'on dispose d'un
autre logiciel que le logiciel de
maastricht qui suppose que effectivement
le marché doit faire la loi et on
s'aperçoit que dans une configuration
comme celle ci le virus s'étend et
planétaire le marché ne peut pas faire
la loi si l'on ferait est-ce que c'est
forcément la faute d' emmanuel macron
parce que clairement
le souci semble qu'on avait pas ces
tests tout comme on n'avait pas les
masques disponibles on n'avait tout
simplement pas les moyens de cette
politique tout simplement est ce que
c'est une politique il n'aurait pas
fallu anticiper bien bien en amont déjà
je ne vous fais pas dire mais vous savez
que macro noté chez hollande que
hollande s'entend bien avec sarko que
sarko était copain comme cochon avec
chirac et que chirac s'entendait bien
finalement avec mitterrand 5 est
globalement depuis que le général de
gaulle est parti en 1969 il ya une seule
et même politique en france c'est celle
du libéralisme les marchés disent
gallois et peu importe que finalement
chances de paquets cadeaux vaguement la
droite vaguement la gauche mais
finalement on a des libéraux dimas très
chiant et c'est la politique globale de
tous ces gens là alors bien sûr macron
n'est pas responsable de tout ça mais il
est responsable de s'inscrire dans un
lignage qui est celui ci et qui fait
effectivement qu'il n'y a pas de masque
et voilà pourquoi il dit que le match ne
sert à rien il n'a pas non plus de tests
et voilà pourquoi il dit les tests ne
servent à rien plutôt que de dire nous
n'avons pas de masse parce que c'est
l'impéritie de la france qui n'existe
plus depuis qu'elle est dans l'europe
nous n'avons pas de test parce que
sénateur ici de la france depuis que la
france n'existe plus et qu'elle est
diluée dans l'europe fédérale qui
elle-même vise une espèce de grand état
universel planétaire où le capital
serait la loi mais de fait puisqu'on ne
fait plus de géopolitique puisqu'on fait
plus de géostratégie puisqu'on ne fait
plus de politique à proprement parler et
bien effectivement on découvre que le
roi est nu et quand il s'agit d'une
pandémie est bien le libéralisme ne
saurait faire la loi parce
qu'effectivement on retrouve les vielles
les vieilles choses le souverainisme les
frontières qu'il faut faire mais l'état
souverain la décision du chef de l'état
le pouvoir et la puissance de la police
et de l'armée
c'est formidable ça fait 20 ans que
l'idée que ces choses là seront
essentielles nécessaires et le l'état
dans lequel nous nous trouvons fait que
nous retrouvons les idéaux de tout sous
leurs listes qui se respecte le premier
tour des municipales qui a été maintenue
effectivement un confinement qui est
arrivé
assez tard parce que ça on avait les
moyens en tout cas de le décider avant
vous vous nous l'expliquer comment
justement pour des raisons purement
économiques ou peut-être le fait de
sous-estimer un danger tout simplement
elle explique pour les par l'extrême
jeunesse d'emmanuel macron car son
innocence au sens étymologique par le
fait qu'il n'est pas un homme politique
par le fait qu'il est un individu placé
par l'état profond les journalistes les
économistes et fiscalistes la finance
enfin tous ces gens là c'est une espèce
d'homme de paille
il ne connaît pas d'autres logiciels que
le logiciel libéral et il ne sait pas
quoi choisir finalement la politique
c'est quoi je vous renvoie à karachi
quelques autres c'est l'art de la
décision ou au général de gaulle le fil
de l'épée c'est le chef qui décide qu'il
faut faire ceci et pas faire cela qu'il
faut aller dans cette direction mais pas
dans celle ci et lui ne sait pas c'est
l'homme du en même temps il veut bien la
droite veut bien la gauche s'il veut
bien dire que il faut se confiner mais
en même temps une fois aller voter qu'
il ne faut pas sortir mais qu'en même
temps on peut aller un match de foot
quand il s'agit de l'italie de la france
que c'est interdit de sortir mais qu'en
même temps pour faire du sport c'est le
contraire d'un chef emmanuel macron donc
de fait c'est un jeune homme qui est
arrivé au bout a alors qu'ils n'avaient
pas 40 ans qui avait avec lui
l'assemblée nationale le sénat et la
totalité des journaux presque deux ou
trois titres et encore et qui a un
cachet tout ça parce que finalement on
découvre d'un seul coup que ce jeune
homme ne sait pas faire de la politique
il est juste l'homme de paille du
capital capitalisme libéralisme de
l'argent du veau d'or et d'un seul coup
le corps d'un virus fait la
démonstration effectivement que la
mécanique et celle ci moi ça fait des
années que je dénonce cette mécanique et
d'un seul coup et de sombres comme au
théâtre et on découvre que le roi est nu
aujourd'hui et on y descend la chine
vient en aide à l'europe la russie
notamment cuba même vient en aide à
l'italie
qu'est ce que ça dit selon vous sa vie
que tous ces gens qui nous allons
présenter comme des libéraux comme des
dictateurs comme des résurgences
d'adolphe hitler hésitations de la
politique je ne dis pas que je souscris
à cette politique
je ne soustrait à la politique d'erdogan
que je souscris à la politique de trumpf
inscrire la politique de poutine je dis
simplement que ces gens là font de la
politique et que nous ne faisons plus de
la politique comme nous estimons que le
capitalisme doit faire la voix
ce que vise macron ce que vis d'europe
matricielle l'europe libérale europe
soutenus par la cia et jean monnet
depuis la sortie de la guerre de la
deuxième guerre mondiale c'est un état
universel pour utiliser le vocabulaire
de young et c'était pas universelle
c'est finalement le gouvernement
planétaire de gens qui estiment que
finalement face à l'économie des peuples
et que l'économie des peuples nous
permet le gouvernement de manière saint
simonienne des techniciens des prétendus
techniciens des prétendus technocrates
et des gens qui savent et d'un seul coup
on découvre tout ça on découvre que
cette machine qui fonctionne et qui fait
de la politique qui fait la politique du
capital et du capitalisme finalement
elle est totalement incapable de gérer
ce genre de choses et que seuls sont
capables de gérer ces choses les gens
qui sont capables de faire de la
politique pas défendre le gouvernement
chinois je dis simplement que en chine
et c'est yvan on a su gérer le problème
alors je vous dis pas il faut que con
con qu'on passe à une dictature c'est
pas mon propos je dis juste que quand
les hommes politiques font de la
politique
quand ils sont capables de décider de
cette belle phrase de nietzsche un oui
ou un non
une ligne droite et bien effectivement
on est capable de souscrire aux chefs et
de dire oui le chef de l'état c'est
quelqu'un avec qui on a envie de dire
oui
si la ligne claire le chef de l'état
aujourd'hui n'a pas de link emmanuel
mâcon clairement sous entend un
infléchissement de sa politique
commençait d'ailleurs avec ses voisins
européens la règle des déficits qui vole
en éclat à quel que soit ce que ça coûte
pour vous il y aura vraiment un avant et
un après on apprend c'est le sont
peut-être moins bien mais je ne crois
pas moi je le jure souvenez-vous de
fillon quand il était premier ministre
de sarkozy qui nous disait que l'état
était en faillite et qu'on ne pouvait
pas effectivement augmenté de quelques
centimes le smic des gens les plus
modestes et les plus pauvres et qui
quelque temps plus tard trouvait tout de
même de l'argent pour bombarder kadhafi
qui était un chef d'état un laïc c'est à
dire qu'il contenait l'islamisme
intégriste on connaît l'histoire pas
d'argent pour les pauvres mais de
l'argent pour bombarder les régimes
islamistes laïques et insolent découvre
effectivement que quand on veut trouver
de l'argent on en trouve donc on voit
bien actuellement que d'un seul coup
toute l'économie ses ventes mais qui
globalement tout trouver de l'argent
pour les les entreprises pour les
artisans pour les gens qui ne peuvent
pas aller travailler en huitièmes un
seul coup toute cette politique
souverainiste
cette fois-ci peut-être c'est un vrai
question clé publique
we made you more c'est à dire que vous
avez l'impression que quand il y avait
un paysan qu'il se pendait tous les
jours ce n'est pas une question de
vivement que quand les gens se jettent
dans l'alcoolisme dans la drogue ou dans
la dépression nerveuse s'était pas non
plus une question uniquement parce
qu'ils étaient chômeurs parce qu'ils
étaient précaires etc pensé que c'était
pas un problème devenu morts sont des ce
sont des morts qu'on ne voit pas alors
évidemment il ya pas de problème mais le
capitalisme fabrique des morts au
quotidien l'avenant seul coup on voit
des cercueils alors on se dit ah
effectivement une visibilité
les gens ont besoin d'image pour penser
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est assez
problématique c'est à dire qu'il ne ne
savent pas penser si on leur montre pas
une montagne de cercueils si vous
montrez une montagne de cercueil d'un
seul coup ils disent ah bon ce n'est
quelque chose à penser dans cette
aventure
si tous les soirs nous montrions visage
du personnage du paysan qui s'est
suicidé dans la journée nous
comprendrions effectivement qu'il ya vu
une épidémie à cause du libéralisme et
que finalement le libéralisme tuer des
gens et ça effectivement le le capital
n'a pas envie de montrer les médias qui
font partie du capitalisme globalement
ou qui reflète l'idéologie du
capitalisme pas intérêt non plus aller à
le montrer mais je crois simplement qu
au sens photographique du terme je pense
à l'époque de la photographie argentique
mais il y avait des révélateur au sens
photographique du terme et d'un seul
coup
ce virus est une espèce de révélateur
qui montre ce qu'est la véritable
photographie de notre époque
nous sommes dans une dictature il
libéral pour utiliser le vocabulaire de
ces gens là quand nous sommes dans la
logique de schengen l'europe maastricht
yonne relève d'une logique libérale
le libéralisme dont on nous a dit qu'il
règlerait la totalité des problèmes ne
règle aucun problème
cette espèce de monstre dont on nous a
dit qu économiquement il serait capable
de faire pièce aussi bien à la russie
aux états unis ou à la chine n'est pas
capable de produire des masques
n'émanant pas de produits il tombe à
cause de l'incapacité à produire des
masques pour les médecins qui l'envoie
merci beaucoup michel onfray d'avoir été
avec nous en direct ce soir sur rtl
france donner son sang c'est ce qu'a
fait elsa une entrepreneuse parisienne
d'une trentaine d'années après s'être
imposé un confinement strict d'une
semaine et c'est finalement autorisé une
sortie solidaire après les appels relier
relayé sur les réseaux sociaux
nos équipes ont subi tout au long de son
trajet à pied de son domicile jusqu'à
l'hôpital bichat dans le 20e
arrondissement
regardez à nicolas abine claire et
emilie gogh h pour les images derniers
préparatifs avant une sortie devenu
exceptionnel que chercher mon petit pré
infectant elsa est sur le point de
quitter son domicile
chose qu'elle ne s'était plus permis
depuis une semaine avant de partir
la jeune femme n'oublie pas lui
désormais précieux sésame l'attestation
de dca quatre déplacements pour motif
ami alain période pour assistance aux
personnes vulnérables aux gardes
d'enfants et entre parenthèses j'ai
rajouté don de sang après quelques jours
de confinement pour elsa l'étonnement
est presque à chaque coin de rue
notamment à la vue de ce parc
aujourd'hui désertés donc là on passe un
joli parc juste à côté de chez moi et
normalement c'est rempli d'enfants de
parents et là il y avait deux personnes
personnes
juste quelques petites peut-être un peu
lunaire
même étonnement devant un supermarché où
elle constate qu'on ne peut désormais
plus entrer sans patienter un peu on va
perçoit que maintenant les gens font la
queue devant les supermarchés alors que
leurs prévisions c'est un peu flippant
en route à une trentaine de minutes plus
tard elle a retrouvé son amie julie
toutes deux se sont donné rendez vous
pour donner leur sang
l'occasion de se revoir mais de loin
mais d'autres ont eu la même idée et en
raison d'une forte affluence
impossible d'entrer sans s'inscrire sur
une liste d'attenté
il faut régulièrement soit appelée soit
le temps d'aller sur ledit site de
l'uefa
les prendre tout simplement rendez vous
en ligne pour pouvoir venir donner votre
sang dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
l'établissement français du sang appelle
à continuer de se rendre dans les
centres de collecte pour un don de sang
plus que jamais vitale pour les patients
et pendant cette pandémie coronavirus la
planète se porterait tel mieux
pollutions marines atmosphérique et
terrestres ont diminué depuis plusieurs
semaines deux pays ont imposé des règles
de confinement illustration en images
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais les tensions entre pékin et
washington se poursuivent la rivalité
entre les deux pays et cette fois-ci
axée autour de ce même sujet le
coronavirus les précisions avec clément
capitale le virus chinois c'est la
formule employée par donald trump chaque
jour pour désigner la pandémie qui
touche le monde entier
le président américain se dit contrarié
par le supposé manque de coopération de
pékin et multiplie ces accusations pour
faire porter la responsabilité du virus
sur le gouvernement chinois cela ce
serait beaucoup mieux passé si on avait
su tout cela quelques mois plus tôt cela
aurait pu être contenue dans la région
de chine
d'où le virus est parti le monde paie le
prix fort pour ce qu'ils ont fait et le
monde paye le prix fort pour ne pas
avoir divulgué l'information
tout le monde le sait pour ce qui est de
croire ce qu'ils disent maintenant
j'espère que c'est vrai qui sait mais
j'espère que c'est vrai des accusations
qui irrite les autorités chinoises pékin
exhorté états unis de cesser de
politiser l'épidémie et de stigmatiser
la chine depuis le premier jour où les
états unis ont provoqué l'incident la
chine a dit aux états unis qu'elle se
réservait le droit de réagir et de
prendre des mesures si les états unis
agissait seul
il en subirait de graves conséquences ce
qui est regrettable c'est que les états
unis du début jusqu'à la fin et fait la
sourde oreille et ignorer les
négociations répéter les allocutions
solennelles de la chine allant de plus
en plus loin dans la mauvaise direction
en attendant aux états unis les bombes
d'un explose les vendeurs font état
d'une nouvelle clientèle
la communauté asiatique qui craindraient
les répercussions raciste en lien avec
le cours aux navires us c'est la fin de
cette émission un peu écourtée vous le
savez en raison de cette crise du
coronavirus qui nous contera à modifier
nos programmes comme tous les médias
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité ce
sera demain matin 8 heures du matin
heure française en attendant les
magazines se poursuivre toute la soirée
sur arte france
[Musique]